- I think everybody thinks
that 2012 was a fluke,
like I got lucky or something.
I'm the first black, white, whatever,
the first woman to win an
Olympic gold medal in boxing
and I did it when I was 17.
I thought I would have
endorsements and sponsorships,
but, you know, that didn't happen.
- Welcome back everybody,
thank you so much.
My guest tonight—
- I am the best female boxer in the world.
- Grew up in Flint, Michigan—
- They’d be like you know,
when you talk you seem
like a bully or you seem pretty cocky.
If you want us to do your
hair we'll do your hair.
And I was like, what's wrong with my hair?
So I can't express how
great of a fighter I am.
Okay, they want the pretty girl.
I back up everything I say.
Nothing is wrong with my personality.
Maybe this is the peak of my career.
Maybe 17 was it.
Maybe one Olympic gold medal
and better start having kids now.
- [Radio] Comes alive,
experience over 40 life-size
moving, breathing dinosaurs
in their natural environment.
See the amazing 20-foot T-Rex,
the life-size triceratops,
stegosaurus.
- Are you getting in the car?
- [Voiceover] Huh?
- Getting in the car?
- Getting in?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- All right, come on.
♫ Going on across the sea ♫
(music and talking on radio)
- [Claressa] People in
Flint are so used to just
somebody being successful
and then falling off.
Flint has limits.
Nobody wants to get in the sky and see
what's beyond the clouds type thing.
I think for some people
that they get start caring.
They don't get out the B.S.
because they kind of get used to it
and they see no other way of life.
I cover Mama end of the bargain with you.
I just went and took you school shopping
and got you two pair of shoes, bro.
I keep telling you go to school,
play football, run track.
- You don't know shit.
(unclear)
- Makeel went to the camera,
Ilikia went to the camera...
- No, are you going to
go to school or not?
That's my question for you.
11:27, bro, are you
going to school or not?
Decide your own life.
You're going to sacrifice
your education for her
'cause you think you know everything.
I said go to school, dumbass.
I'm-a talk to you later,
bro, because you're
gonna make me mad and I
don't want to get there.
- No, your ass gonna make me mad.
- And what you gonna do about it?
(sirens)
I know that my family
wants to see me do well.
But they don't know that some
of the things that they do
can hurt me doing well.
You know, we always had a
deal, even when I was younger,
once you step into the
gym all outside problems
stay out the gym, you know?
Felt like I have everything
to lose, 'cause I do.
(humming)
I feel like the longer I'm
here the further I drift away.
Drift back into being here.
I really, you know, don't just want
to walk out on them,
but I've always kept my
career first before anything.
So that's why I'm like the longer I stay
the worse it is for
me, so it's time to go.
(dinging)
I’m-a hit you up, though.
I love you too, baby.
I have nothing but time to think.
Nothing but time to look out the window,
wonder about what I'm-a
do 15, 20 years from now.
I have to win to go back
to the Olympics again.
If I don't win the Olympic
trials, there is no Olympics,
there is no more USA Boxing stipend.
Will I have to move back to Flint?
I do believe that I can win
another Olympic gold medal.
But just because I believe it
don't mean it's gonna happen.
- [Voiceover] Good evening
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the Olympic
team trials for women's boxing.
Here in ring number one
in Memphis, Tennessee,
these are the best 24
female boxers in the nation
competing for the chance
to go to Rio de Janeiro
for the 2016 Olympic Games.
(applause and whistling)
- [Voiceover] Women's
middleweight winners bracket.
Claressa Shields in the red
corner from Flint, Michigan
against Tika Hemingway in the
blue corner from Pennsylvania.
- I can't afford to have a bad fight
or have a close fight anymore.
They're gonna be a lot harder
on me now that I’m, you know, top dog.
And it's either dominate or don't.
- [Voiceover] She understands
this time around
that it's much more than
just about winning gold.
That her image, that her personality
play a much bigger role.
- People said that when you
talk you seem like a bully
or you seem pretty cocky.
I don't have to change myself
for people to accept me.
I don't care what nobody thinks.
(bell rings)
(yelling, groaning)
- [Voiceover] Right now, right now.
- [Voiceover] She's hurt.
(yelling)
(groaning)
(many people yelling)
- [Claressa] If you look
up the word beautiful woman
in the dictionary it should
have my face right there.
It should have me in a boxing uniform
with my gloves on posing.
To box the way that I
do, that's what I think
is really beautiful.
(groaning, people yelling)
(bell rings)
- And now your winner
of the women's 165-pound
weight class, fighting
out of the red corner...
(cheering and applause)
Claressa Shields.
- [Claressa] I think
everybody thinks that 2012
was a fluke, like I
got lucky or something.
Eh, okay.
They can't think that now.
(upbeat instrumental music)